So there's a couple of really nice things to be
able to say about single-link clustering. So one of them
is that it's deterministic, right? So we run the same
algorithm, and unless there's ties in the distances, it, it will
give us an answer, which is, which is nice. Doesn't
require any kind of randomized optimization. Another thing about it is
that if you're doing this process in a space where
the distances represent edge lengths of the graph then this is
actually the same as a minimum spanning tree algorithm.
>> Hm.
>> And another nice property is that the running
time of the algorithm is actually relatively friendly and
can be characterized so let's, let's think that through.
So let's imagine we've got n points or objects
that we want to cluster. And we've got K
clusters that we want as our as our target
at the end. Which of these different running times
best characterizes the running time of single link clustering?